Marie-Pierre m'a fait découvrir
les valeurs du Mouvement Démocrate
Bonjour, je m'appelle Louise Daniel,
j'ai 21 ans.
Je suis secrétaire générale adjointe
des Jeunes Démocrates
et présidente des Jeunes Démocrates
en Bretagne.
J'ai réalisé une licence de droit public
à l'Université de Vannes
et maintenant je suis à Paris-Saclay.
Je fais un master de politique de communication
et d'affaires publiques
et puisque ce master est en alternance,
je me spécialise
dans les politiques publiques agricoles.
Depuis toute petite
je m'intéresse à la politique
et depuis deux ans
je me suis engagée au sein
des Jeunes Démocrates.
Cet engagement,
il a commencé
grâce à Marie-Pierre Vedrenne
qui est députée européenne
et élue en Bretagne.
Marie-Pierre m'a fait découvrir
les valeurs du Mouvement Démocrate
que sont
l'écologie, l'humanisme,
le projet européen,
entre autres.
Et c'est cet ensemble de valeurs
qui m'a fait adhérer au MoDem.